good afternoon members officers and
members of the press
welcome to this extraordinary cabinet
meeting
um just some housekeeping if the fire
alarm
is activated to vacate the offices of
other stairs please do not use the lifts
assembly in holy Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
the following members have asked to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
items three
counselors Whitehead item four councilor
Whitehead
item seven councilor Auburn
item three Council Yates certainly
is any other members wish to speak under
20.1
so we will move on to the next item
which is
we have no apologies for absence the
cabinet are all present this afternoon
item two decorations of interest does
anyone have any interest to declare in
the items of business on the agenda this
afternoon
no thank you Charles
item three is a budget monitoring
2022-23 report number one to introduce
councilor David Saunders
thank you leader
this is the first budget monitoring
report for this year
we are forecasting an overspend of just
under 1.8 million pounds against our
general fund Revenue budget
one of the main factors causing this
overspend is the additional demands in
the housing service with more homeless
placements
in response to this the council has
reviewed and is delivering its
homelessness strategy action plan
we are regularly monitoring the levels
of homelessness and we are recruiting
more staff and commissioning new
services to address the increasing need
for support
our financial pressures are detailed in
the report but include additional agency
Staffing requirements in the waste and
recycling service and also higher gas
and electricity costs
our general fund Capital program is
showing a substantial under spend this
is in part due to the phasing and timing
of a number of Grant funded projects
some of which are recommended to be
slipped into later years of the program
in the HRA there is a marginal forecast
overspend of 119 000 pounds against the
revenue budget whereas within our
Capital program we are proposing a
number of budget variations so that the
profile of our budget is closer closely
matched to our revised expectations for
the timing of future spending
finally there are a number of budget
adjustments that are detailed within the
report
which are recommended to council for
approval
as such I move the recommendations
leader thank you
Council
head
thank you very much leader
at 2.12 the reality of the housing
situation we face is clear
having already moved 400 000 pounds to
support the ongoing crisis and overspend
of 880 000 indicates the level of strain
our residents and consequently our
services are under
can I ask cabinet if there's been any
further progress on securing extra
funding for housing through previously
mentioned dialogue with central
government
as our current allocations are nowhere
near sufficient for the level of need we
have currently
our 2122 ref sleeping initiative award
for a single year was one million 784
and 495 pounds
the current award took over three years
is three million eight hundred and eight
thousand and two hundred and seventy
pounds which if divided across the
number of years it is intended to
support is a reduction of one million
five hundred and forty five thousand
pounds with 215.
in terms of central funding at a time
when we have lost the 5 million Kent
homeless connect fund for the county and
have much higher need in terms of
current and future homelessness and
rough sleeping
in light of this do we have any current
or future news from central government
in terms of the extra funding we so
desperately need
secondly in relation to the forecast
overspend of 180 000 at 2.42 on
electricity and gas bills due to the
current energy crisis can I ask what
measures we have put in place to
mitigate the predicted oath spend thank
you
all right so as soon as if you'd like to
respond please I would indeed thank you
councilor Whitehead for your uh
questions
um I can confirm that we do have
um in hand at the moment a review of our
homelessness strategy
um but I think I need to refer to
our officers behind for a more detailed
explanation of where we are with regards
to Grants and the other questions you
asked with regards regards to the
housing finances thank you thank you
thank you
um so in terms of grant funding there's
been no additional funding allocated
over and above
that the funding that was included in
the budget when we set it back in
February at the start of the year
um as Council unders
has already said and we are looking at
strategy we're looking at recruiting
some additional offices so using the
additional 400 000 that we put into the
budget to partly mitigate some of the
pressures use that flexibly in a way
that we hope that we can bring down some
of the costs of the service and that's
something that Bob Porter and his team
are looking to move forward with as soon
as practically possible
um
Council Saunders would you like me to
address the questions in relation to
energy as well I'm happy to refer back I
think I think your fingers more firmly
on the pulse than mine from our earlier
meeting
um I think think either yourself or Matt
could responding that connection yeah uh
Matthew salmon may be able to add some
more
um but in terms of our energy usage we
do have
um
the benefits of some of our energy
contracts having been fixed at a point
so effects we bought in advance unlike
sort of residential uh properties we're
able to fix some of the prices of our
energy use in advance so we've not been
exposed to the same extent that we're
seeing in the residential Market we do
have some flexibility in terms of the
amount of contingency we put aside in
the budget for energy and we're using
that flexibly
over and above that we're looking
um not just as part of a means of
reducing cost but part of our Net Zero
strategy we've been looking a number of
initiatives and we've got our action
plan in place to try and reduce our
energy usage across the short to medium
term as well
thank you
okay thank you and councilor Whitehead
um
councilor Yates
uh thank you leader
um three points uh start with the
recommendation for this additional 100
000 pounds for the property
um resource just want to say that fully
support that proposal I think it's
really sensible and um fingers crossed
should bring in additional
um much needed Revenue into the council
um on
the first the so two questions the first
one's on Maritime
um it's looking like there's a
250k lower than budget expectations due
to um
some uh Global shortage of components to
manufacture vehicles
um do they does the council expect this
to be your like a one-off shortfall or
is this going to be a recurring
um do they anticipate this could be a
recurring shortfall in the port and
second question
um recommendation to mentions 100 000
pounds some Southern water uh 10 000
pounds having been spent
um just want to know where that has been
spent and what governance was in place
um for that expenditure thanks
I think again I'm going to have to refer
to office to be high below but I mean my
my personal opinion um with regards to
any costings is that it's not going to
be a one-off
um as you well know I tend to be a
pessimist so I take a pessimistic review
on situations where we stand with
regards to external funding but if I can
refer to both those points to
um officers behind me thank you
thank you councilor
um in relation to Maritime so the way
the budget's set up is that they have a
income Target that's not specified to a
particular customer base so the port has
quite a diverse range of income that it
generates some of it's more predictable
than others that has this thing can talk
this income Target within it that's more
um what is unspecified typically in
previous years we have generated a fair
amount of income from the import of of
uh vehicles that has been less uh than
in previous years because of the
aforementioned shortage or delays and
vehicle recovery it's difficult to sort
of forecast into future how quickly the
supply chain will speed up but we will
be looking at it as part of the overall
budget setting process for the 23 24
budget setting process along with other
sort of opportunities to generate more
income from not just the port but our
wider property estate as well in terms
of the
um the hundred thousand pound from
Southern water so there's some more
information there you'll see at 4.2 the
report so there's improvements some of
the coastal shelters was the approval
for that so because the the
authorization with it because it's
within
um uh it was ten thousand pounds up to
this point in time I've got the
authority to buy money around within
budgets up to 20 000 pounds so
um as a temporary means it was able I
was able to put funding in place to
allow that scheme to go forward ahead of
um the uh The Wider scheme being
allocated for the hundred thousand pound
because I only have allocation Authority
up to
um fifty thousand pound for violence
that's okay
thank you
um
Chris for clarifying that um
so this has been
moved by councilor Saunders do I have a
second bar
councilor Bob bayford
do members agree
it's item four
is
to approve lease arrangements for 53 to
57 High Street Margate as part of the
Margate leveling up fund project to
introduce councilor Rhys Pugh
thank you chair I'm pleased to be
bringing forward this report to Cabinet
in order to be able to continue progress
on this project delivering the Margate
level out fund scheme to deliver a
digital campus in Margate High Street
we've already approved the provision of
a grant from the 11 out fund to East
Kent College group and this decision
marks a step in gaining approval from
homes England to lease the building to
East Kent College group for delivery of
this project I would like to recommend
that we give delegated authority to the
director of regeneration and the act in
deputy chief executive to seek approval
for the heads of terms as members of the
joint venture board between thanet
District Council and homes England
that we give dedicated authority to the
interim director of property in
consultation with the principal surveyor
and the economic development portfolio
holder to agree heads of terms and enter
into the relevant negotiations for at
least with at least with East Kent
College group
and that we give delegated authority to
the interim head of legal and monitoring
to prepare and complete the lease and
all other ancillary documents on the
terms to be agreed and sign all
documents necessary to give effect to
the lease agreement thank you
thank you counselor Pugh to speak under
20.1 councilor Whitehead
thank you leader
and see very clearly that there are
significant benefits to educational
delivery and Community Support in terms
of the proposed usage of the building
and I support those aims entirely
but I'm also very aware that the aims of
external funding often require
significant legal Scaffolding in order
to become results that match those aims
as a 10-year nil cost lease is being
proposed which is significant for a
building this large as well as a
subletting Clause can I ask if the
employment aims of the leveling up
funding have been incorporated into the
terms of the lease in terms of specific
requirements of ekc and any group
subletting such as permanent contracts
for employees guarantee of a real living
wage for employees or provision of
apprenticeships within their business
models as well as within the educational
offer thank you
thank you Council lighthead councilor
Pugh I'd imagine you refer that to
Louise okay
yes I will leader yes
sorry
um we because it's part of the leveling
up fund alongside it will set the grant
agreement so in the previous cabinet
decision we have procured external
lawyers to put together a grant
agreement to cover the 6.3 million and
within that all of the conditions that
relate to the
um leveling up fund bid all of the
outputs and outcomes that ekc group
proposed through that funding program
will all be included within that Grant
agreement and they will have to
um report on those on a quarterly basis
at the moment as it's dance there isn't
anything about kind of salaries and
living wage and things like that around
employers but it's certainly something
that we can look at albeit there is
quite a lot of outputs that are linked
with the funding that already sit within
that Grant agreement and that Grant
agreement and the lease agreement will
sit side by side
thank you that's good to know that that
could be looked at
I don't have any more speakers on that
um councilor Pew have you uh moved this
item
uh yes chair I move this item do I have
a secondary councilor George cup do
members agree
item five is the future High Street fund
update
back to councilor Pew to introduce
[Music]
thank you chair
the aim of the future High Street fund
was to renew and reshape High streets
with the inclusion of other uses to Inc
to drive increases in football
the council was successful in a bid that
included the development of a creative
workspace in Ramsgate Town Center
unfortunately due to change in
circumstances the building originally
identified to deliver the workspace
project in has been leased to a private
business since then the council has been
working hard to identify new sites in
order to be able to deliver this project
so that we do not have to return this
much needed funding
a change in private sector investment in
Ramsgate has provided some challenges to
this project although we know that there
is still great demand for Creative work
state workspace provisioning I would
like to recommend that cabinet note the
report presented by way of an update on
the delivery of the future High Street
fund thank you
thank you Council approach
I have no speakers under this item so do
I have a secondar
councilor Jill Baker do members agree
item six is for the exclusion of press
and public
foreign
so I will introduce this
um
so everyone is clear as to why this is
happening
um the cabinet is asked to agree that
the public can press be excluded from
the meeting for item agenda item seven
as it contains exempt information as
defined in paragraph three or schedule
12a part one of the Local Government Act
1972.
so I am moving that do I have a second
off councilor Bob bayford do cabinet
agree
so I'd ask members of the press and
public to
leave the chamber thank you